hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so excited
that you're excited to study God's word
with us and that you're taking the time
to join us in this powerful study I want
to share with you how you can submit
your questions you can send your
questions via text to 618 228
3975 again that's 618 228 3975 or you
can email us at bible QA
3abn.org
that's 3abn uncore official we
definitely want your questions and uh we
have some wonderful students of the word
who will answer those questions from the
Bible and it's not not their opinion
it's from the word of God here with me
today and we have Pastor John L Kang
it's great to have you here good to be
here and I thank you for your questions
that Force us to go back into the word
and find something new amen and we have
H Pastor John deny it's great to have
you on the program as well it's a
blessing to be here and it's also a
blessing to hear the answers that uh the
panel brings out because I learned
something as well amen amen and next to
you we have Pastor James raffy we've
spent a lot of time together we sure
have doing A2 episodes of Salvation and
symbols and signs man it's good to be
here looking forward to the program and
all the questions and answers what do
you enjoy about this program I love
digging into the word of God and there's
a couple of questions in here that have
puzzled me uh and when I get an
opportunity to try to answer them I
learn and that's what I really
appreciate about this program learning
more amen more about the word of God
Amen well before we dive into the
questions dive into the word of God we
should go to him in prayer Pastor LOM
Kang would you pray for us sure gracious
father loving Lord your word is a lamp
unto our feet and a light unto our paths
but we dare not step into the light
without asking for the guidance of your
Holy Spirit and so Lord send your Holy
Spirit to Enlighten our minds to
illuminate your word and to control our
thoughts as we submit them to the
molding influence of your SP Spirit May
the answers be bible-based and clear and
may the hearers also have their minds
primed to receive what you intend to
direct their lives but may you always
receive the glory in Jesus
name amen amen amen Pastor rafy will
come to you with this first question
here can you explain Luke chapter 16: 8
and N this is from Maurice you know
Maurice this is one of those questions
that when I received it I thought oh
that is a a tough question I'm not sure
if I have an answer to that one so I
went to dig into the word of God it's a
very powerful uh section of scripture
Jesus Christ in the context of this is
uh sitting with publicans and sinners
he's surrounded by people who are
interested in some of those people are
enemies they're Pharisees and Sadducees
and they're trying to find fault with
Jesus that's their focus so let's just
read the verses uh Luke 16 8-9 and the
Lord commanded the unjust Steward
because he had done wisely for the
children of this world are in their
generation wiser than the children of
light and I say unto you verse 9 make to
yourselves Friends of the Mammon of
unrighteousness that when you fail they
may receive you into Everlasting
habitations now Christ is sitting here
again with publicans and Sinners and
he's saying something that surprises at
least surprises the religious leaders
he's telling them this parable of this
unjust Steward who makes friends with
the world and is wiser than religious
people he's specifically rebuking the
scribes and the Pharisees but the
principle in this Parable this short
story that Christ is trying to bring
forth is the principle of wisdom he uses
that word twice wisely and wiser it's a
double emphasis on wisdom and that's
what we want to pull out when we look at
Bible verses that are difficult we want
to look for the principle what is God
pointing to what is he directing us to
and in this particular situation he's
directing us to wisdom let's be wise so
let's just look at that in the context
of the principles that are brought out
in relationship to wisdom what is the
unjust Steward doing that is wise what
number one this is what he's doing the
unjust Steward gave serious
consideration to his future all right so
a lot of us don't do that we fail to do
that sometimes we just go blly along as
if you know we didn't have a care in the
world and we're not worried about
anything and it's not that we need to be
anxious but there are times when we need
to consider the future and number two
second uh principle he made preparation
for the difficult times ahead when you
start considering the future you're
inclined to make preparation for the
future and this is wise and this is what
the unjust Steward was doing think about
it his stewardship was going to be taken
away from him and he thought what am I
going to do for my future so he's
thinking about his future I know what
I'm going to do this is what I'm going
to do he starts making preparation for
the future number three he
exercises mercy and forgiveness toward
those who were in debt to him now he's
an unjust Steward but he's still
exercising mercy and forgiveness he's
basically saying I'm going to forgive
this person I'm going to forgive this
person you say you owe this much you say
you owe this much and as I'm merciful to
them they'll be merciful back to me that
is a principle that's being brought out
here in this story and then number four
he made friends in this world by doing
this right he actually was able to
connect with people in the world and
make make friends with them by giving
mercy and forgiveness and you know you
think about this when Jesus failed when
he died on the cross the thief the
unrighteous Mammon next to him received
him into Everlasting habitations that
was the final point that they would
receive you into Everlasting habitations
in fact when you think about this it's a
picture of Christ in a sense because the
publicans and sinners excuse me the
scribes and Pharisees are looking at
Christ as an unjust Steward that's the
way they see him in Gethsemane Jesus had
serious gave serious consideration to
his future he then made a serious
preparation for difficult times ahead he
exercised mercy and forgiveness to those
who were in debt on the cross and then
he made friends of this world uh by
doing this like the thief who chose to
receive him into Everlasting habitations
just before he died saying remember me
when you come into your kingdom amen
context and principle when Understanding
God's word amen well said pastor densey
can you please explain Judges chapter
14:4 as it relates to Samson did God
prompt Samson to choose a wife from the
Philistines Camp you
can kind of come to that conclusion as
you look at the verse but let's go ahead
and begin in Judges chapter
14:3 then his father and mother said to
him there is no
woman among the daughters of your
brethren or among all my people that you
must go and get a away from the UNC
circumcised Philistines and Samson said
to his father get her for me for she
pleases me well and it says in verse
four but his father and mother did not
know that it was of the of the Lord that
he was seeking an occasion to move
against the Philistines for all that
time the Philistines had dominion over
Israel and so we see here the question
is did God prompt him to do this notice
the last last part of verse three it
says get her for me for she pleases me
well it was really Samson's
decision that to have this woman as his
wife and in those days the the parents
were the ones who took initiative in in
in bringing about a marriage uh coming
together but he Samson insisted get her
from me she pleases me well it was his
choice his decision but God used that
wrong decision MH to bring about uh the
punishment of the Philistines which they
deserved am and so uh we should not look
at this as an idea that God will prompt
us to do something wrong because he has
something uh good that he wants to
accomplish out of it God uses our
decisions even when they're bad if we if
we follow him if we choose to serve him
he uses those decisions he tries to make
the best out of the mess that that we
make and this is the case with Samson
the Lord tried to make the best out of
the mess that he decided to make and
really what do we see when Samson
decided to marry this woman he suffered
he suffered and uh it was not a good
choice but God used that as as an
occasion to again bring the punishment
to the Philistines which they deserved
yeah knowing how that story ends yes
well yes you know how it ends you know
it's he died in the process yeah yes
absolutely make sure you pray and ask
God who you should marry you get with
the wrong one there's going to be some
problems excellent answer uh Pastor
lomma Kang why did Jesus curse the Fig
Tree Jesus came to save that which is
lost yet he cursed a fig tree that
didn't bear fruit he was very
disappointed being hungry and expecting
such a blooming tree to have fruit on it
God must get disappointed in us when we
portray outer Christianity
but have nothing inside is that the
context of this scripture this is from
Tony out of Canada well fig trees first
came on the scene right after the fall
of Man you know Adam and Eve swed figes
together to hide their shame and when
you look at the Bible you find that
clearly fig trees uh take a major role
if you put the phrase fig tree you find
more than 40 references in the
scriptures but in most of those
references it's a reference to the
children of Israel in the Old Testament
here is one of the examples in Hosea 9
uh verse 10 I found Israel like grapes
in the wilderness I saw your fathers as
the first fruits on the Fig Tree in its
first season but now he talks about the
way they departed in obedience but they
went to bail pure and separated
themselves to that shame they became an
Abomination like the thing they loved so
right away he begins to apply the Fig
Tree to the children of Israel also in
the New Testament you you find that the
prophecy of Daniel 9:
24-27 was a probationary time for the
children of Israel to get their lives
together and there were six or seven
things he told them to do the nutshell
reconcile your transgressions and
prepare yourself to be the one to invite
the Messiah into the world but they
didn't and the Bible says in Matthew
chapter 21 uh beginning with verse 19
and seeing a fig tree by the road he
came to it and found nothing on it but
leaves and said to it let no fruit grow
on you ever again immediately the Fig
Tree withered away and when the
disciples saw it they Marvel saying how
did the Fig Tree wither away so soon and
now this is Jesus in his Earthly
Ministry he's still looking for fruit on
the trees in other words in the lives of
the leadership of Israel and in his
people the one he chose to get the
gospel to the world so they ask how did
it wither so soon and Jesus sends it in
Matthew 21:21 so Jesus answered and said
to them assuredly I say to you if you
have faith and do not doubt
you will not only do what was done to
the Fig Tree but also if you say to this
mountain be removed and be cast into the
sea it will be done and then he goes a
little farther he starts narrowing down
the the application of the Fig Tree in
the Book of Luke 13: 6 to9 and we know
it's a parable because he says he also
spoke this Parable saying a certain man
had a fig tree planted in his Vineyard
the plant the one that planted the
vineyard is Christ The Vineyard is the
field of the Lord and he came seeking
fruit on it and found none then he said
to The Keeper of the vineyard look for
three years I have come seeking fruit on
it on this fig tree and found none cut
it down why does it use up the ground
but he answered and said sir let it
alone this year also until I dig around
it and fertilize it and if it bears
fruit well but if not after that you can
cut it down and that is the mercy of the
Lord saying give them time to get their
lives together but you know they didn't
and then you get in Matthew chapter uh
23:
37-38 uh oh Jerusalem Jerusalem the ones
who kills the prophets and Stones those
who are sent to her how often I wanted
to gather your children together as a
hen gathers her chicks under her wings
but you were not willing see your house
is Left To You desolate and then so you
begin to see well how does that apply to
the children of Israel Mark 11 I'm just
going to read verse 21 looking at the
children of Israel verse 20 and 21 now
in the morning as he passed by they saw
the fig tree dried up from the roots and
Peter remembering said to him Rabbi look
the Fig the Fig Tree which you cursed
has withered away and so you see the
Lord had been beared long with the
children of Israel in their leadership
and in Acts chapter 13 finally he says
in verse 46 it was necessary that the
word of God should be SP spoken to you
first but since you rejected and judge
yourselves Unworthy of everlasting life
behold we turn to the Gentiles what was
the problem Romans 9:6 but it's not that
the word of God has taken no effect for
they are not all Israel who are of
Israel so he called them for a purpose
they did not fulfill it and he turned to
the Gentiles that was the reason why the
Fig Tree was cursed wow excellent
excellent thank you for unpacking that
we should never abuse God's grace and
his mercy and praise him for being so
patient with us I don't I mean where
would we be if if he weren't that's
right scary scary thought uh Pastor
raffy why does Jesus have to destroy
sinners in a lake of fire that seems a
bit harsh for a god of love that is a
really good question and make no mistake
about it uh it is Harsh it's very harsh
however God has no alternative the Bible
tells us in Hebrews 12: 29 that God our
God is a consuming fire and that is
especially in relationship to sin God is
just and God is fair toward sinners in
fact Justice or fairness is an attribute
of his character of love as noted in the
very context of his law which is a
transcript of his character in Exodus
chap 24 through6 you shall make no other
for yourself no carved image or any
likeness of anything that is in heaven
above or that is in the earth beneath or
that is in the water under the Earth and
you shall not bow down to them nor serve
them for I the Lord your God am a
jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children to the third
and fourth generations of them that hate
me but showing Mercy to thousands of
those who love me and keep my
commandments so God's character of love
does not forbid his Justice in carrying
out the penalty of sin upon the
transgressor of his law rather the love
of God necessitates the exercise of
Justice upon sin and that's why Jesus
died to show us the consequence of sin
is death death and to save us from that
penalty by taking our penalty upon
himself in our place as us and for us
according to SEC Corinthians 2
Corinthians 5:21 he became sin for us so
so far God has actually shielded
Humanity from the final encounter with
him he wants us to be able to stand in
his fiery presence and survive and many
will the Lake of Fire and the sea of
glass mingled with fire are both too hot
for sinners in fact the Greek word for
SE and Lake are used interchangeably in
the Bible so the inspired question is
asked in Isaiah 33 the Sinners and iron
are afraid fearfulness and sees the
Hypocrites who among us shall dwell in
the devouring fire who among us shall
dwell with the Everlasting burnings and
the inspired answer is given He Who
Walks righteously and speaks uprightly
he who despises the gain of oppressions
he who gestures with his hands refusing
bribes who stops his ears from hearing
of Bloodshed and shuts his eyes from
seen evil he will dwell on high his
place of Defense shall be the Fortress
of rocks bread shall be given him his
water shall be sure Isaiah 33:14 to16
inevitably those who have held on to
their sins who have lived and spoken
unrighteously without genuine repentance
who have gained wealth through
oppression without genuine repentance
those who have taken bribes and listened
to Bloodshed and watched evil with all
all without genuine repentance all those
who have lived the life of sin without
genuine repentance for sin and
surrendered to Jesus as their savior all
who take sin upon themselves will reap
the full consequence of their sin at the
hand of a loving God who as John pastor
lomma King said who cursed the Fig Tree
there's going to come a time of judgment
there's going to come a time when mercy
ends and we receive the consequences of
our
choices and really when you when you
think about that like why would someone
who's so set on sinning want to spend
eternity in a place where we're
worshiping and praising God that's right
you know and and it seems like a lot of
people want sin and salvation and they
don't go hand in hand excellent answer
that's true thank you amen Pastor deny
in light of God's clear instruction to
the Israelites not to marry the Heathen
Deuter in Deuteronomy chapter 7 how then
did Esther a Jew end up marrying a
heathen King is it that God permits some
things for some people that are outside
his will but that will accomplish his
greater purpose based on this case what
would we say to a young Christian man or
woman who chooses to marry a
non-Christian in clear violation of 2
Corinthians chapter 6 ver14 this is from
Bernard out of Jamaica thank you Bernard
uh this is a very good question and uh
there may be people that look at the
story of Esther and say well it looks
like you can get some good results out
of this something good can come out of
this and May perhaps lead them to marry
someone that is not within God's will
thinking that hey something good can
come out of this or even the idea that I
think I can convert her I think I can
convert him and this is a task that
belongs to the Lord he's the one that
converts people so we shouldn't uh look
at this what he's going to be my project
and so this is a dangerous dangerous uh
thing to do and I would like to go ahead
and read 2 Corinthians 6:14 that you
mentioned for this sake of of people
that may not know what this says it says
in 2 Corinthians 6:14 do not be
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers why it says for what
Fellowship has righteousness with
lawlessness and what communion has light
with Darkness so we see here that the
Bible is giving us a clear principle
that we need to avoid getting married
with
unbelievers because there is there
really no Union that's going to take
place and and it brings out this very
interesting comparison what communion
has light with Darkness does vinegar and
water mix no it does not you can shake
it all you want try to blend it together
but it will still separate the same
thing happens with when a Believer
marries an unbeliever someone is going
to be affected and you can hope that the
unbeliever will become a Believer but in
most cases we we hear stories we've
heard we've received many calls for
people that I regret marrying this
person that is not a Christian and so I
would encourage you to uh those that are
considering uh marrying someone that's
not a Believer listen to what God is
telling you to avoid unnecessary
suffering you know I remember as a young
a young person I used to I love children
so I used to uh carry the children of
the uh the married people and they would
here you go and they were happy to uh
let me carry them and I remember some
married people say oh Johnny you love
children don't get married don't get
married it it it appears that it's a a
difficult thing even for believers to
get along because the devil's going to
try to make it make it that way uh so
what about a Believer with an unbeliever
greater problems more problems and
following what Deuteronomy said you
mentioned I'd like to read that as well
God is telling his people there and
tells us to day nor shall you make
marriages with them you shall not give
your daughters to their
sons nor take their daughters for your
son for they will turn your sons away
from following me to serve other gods so
the anger of the Lord will be arouse
against you and destroy you suddenly it
is a dangerous dangerous thing light
cannot miss with mix with Darkness pray
and ask the Lord to guide you and who
who you should marry this is one of the
most important
decisions of life and you have to
consider that Satan may may be laying a
trap for you to lead you astray from
following the Lord and he can use these
things that look good and sound good to
lead you astray and this is one of the
areas where he works very effectively
because he knows that he can cause great
harm when a Believer marries an
unbeliever he has first ground to work
and create problems for you that you do
not need to get into so don't let your
sight or your passion cause you to marry
someone that's going to give you greater
problem than you need and if you already
made that decision ask the Lord to help
you make the best of it but try to be a
light for that person that is an
unbeliever if you're already in that
situation amen amen well said I like
that don't don't uh create a project or
don't look at them as a project don't
get with them for who they can become
you know you get with them uh for who
they are in that moment too Pastor LOM
Kang were Lucifer and his angels cast
out of Heaven before or after Adam and
Eve were created okay thank you so much
and by the way I just want to comment I
like that oil and vinegar example it's
so true how difficult life is when you
are unequally yolked thank you so much
for the question you know the Bible
doesn't specifically mention the time
frame but it had to be during the
creation
of the world or else God could not have
warned Adam and Eve of the potential
that existed in the garden and it was
very clear he says of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil you shall not
eat of it for and the day you eat of it
you will surely die now the tree itself
all by itself was a test but that test
was enhanced by the serpent being in the
garden and he couldn't be there he was
there obviously before the fall Paul
suggests that we know in Genesis it
makes it very clear about Eve going to
the tree and having the conversation you
could read that in Genesis chter 3 but
the Apostle Paul in 2 Corinthians 11:3
speaks about the very same dangers that
presented itself to the children of
Corinth he says but I fear lest somehow
as the serpent deceived Eve by his
craftiness so your minds may be
corrupted from the Simplicity that is in
Christ and so the timing of the of the
event to me for some people it may make
a huge difference but to me what's more
relevant is that it happened at all and
there was a war in heaven Revelation 12:
7-9 you know the Bible says war broke
out in heaven so Christ and his angels
fought against the dragon as his angels
and it says in verse 9 of Revelation 12
so the Great Dragon that Serpent of all
called the devil and Satan who deceives
the whole world he was cast to the Earth
and his angels were cast out with him
now consider for a moment not only the
devil being the devil being cast out and
I think I mentioned this on one of our
prior programs and I want to say it here
there's only one devil mhm but there are
many demons so the test there as it was
directly to directly to Eve the
deception then you have in the
wilderness Temptation the devil tempting
Christ and then you find in 1 John 2
ver1 15 all that is in the world the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
and the pride of life the only three
types of temptations that exists in our
world but suffice it to say in answer to
your question I firmly believe that it
happened during the creation because had
it not happened during the creation it
couldn't happen after the fall because
Satan was uh a would I say an accomplice
in the fall of Man he facilitated that
he didn't force Adam to sin you know
Romans 5:12 says just as through one man
sin entered the world it doesn't even
blame Satan for sin entering the world
so today we can't say the devil made me
do it it is by the choice we make that
sin enters Our Lives in a in a more
meaningful way even though we are
already born in sinned and shapen in
iniquity and Romans 3:23 all of sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God so
the answer is and I would say focus more
on the fact that it did happen the
timing to me is of least relevance
because it was clear that he was in the
garden and Eve was deceived by the
Serpent's presence amen I'd love that
you can't say that the devil made me do
it can't say it AB absolutely no
temptation is over overtaken you but
such as is common God always makes a way
out amen amen you know you might be
sitting there wondering well I'm hearing
all these great questions but I've never
sent any questions into 3abn today Bible
Q&A I want to share how you can do that
text your questions to 618 228
3975 again that's 618 228
3975 or email us at bible QA
3abn.org a.tv or if you're on Instagram
send us a direct message at
3abn official again that's 3abn uncore
official Pastor
rafy if you've been a Christian and you
turn your back on the Lord and then come
back to him but then go back into
drinking and stuff will he forgive you
and can you be a Christian again this is
from Linda out of Washington yes Linda
God will not cast out the one who comes
to him through Jesus Christ this is what
the Bible says John 6:37 all that the
father gives me will uh will come to me
and the one who comes to me I will in no
wise cast out and if you only had one
Bible verse to take you into the kingdom
of God that Bible verse would be
sufficient in 1 John chap 1 and verse 9
it says if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness in Micah 7 beginning
verse 7 it says therefore I will look to
the Lord I will wait for the Lord of my
salvation God will hear me do not
rejoice over me my enemy when I fall I
will arise when I sit in darkness the
Lord will be a light unto me I will bear
the indignation of the Lord because I've
sinned against him until he pleads my
case and executes judgment for me
Justice for me he will bring me forth to
the light I will see his righteousness
who is a God Like You pardoning iniquity
passing over the transgression of the
remnant of his Heritage he does not
retain his anger forever because he
Delights in Mercy he will again have
compassion on us and he will subdue our
iniquities he will cast all of our sins
into the depths of the sea in fact the
Bible indicates that Jesus forgives us
again and again and again when it says a
just man falls seven times and Rises up
again Proverbs
24:16 so it's not in the falling Linda
it's in the rising up again it's in the
going to Jesus it's in the confessing
our sins it's in believing that although
we bear the indignation of the Lord
because we've sinned against him he will
bring us forth unto the light in Matthew
chapter 18 Peter came and basically said
Lord how many times should I forgive my
brother three times three times it's
like woo that was big and Jesus
responded by trying to give Peter and us
a picture of God's forgiveness toward us
and he said no I say not unto you until
excuse me three times seven times I say
not unto you seven times but 70 times
seven and in doing that Jesus was in a
very symbolic way directing Peter and us
to a prophecy in Daniel chapter n Pastor
L Kang mentioned it earlier the 70 we
prophecy which is 70 weeks of years or
490 years for 490 years God had borne
long with his it with his people his
church his bride Israel in and out and
in and out of sin back and forth and
back and forth for that whole period of
time and Peter was being reminded it
isn't as though God is taking a record
one 2 three we get to 399 and 420 and
we're almost 490 and almost got no God
is simply saying that he bears with us
for a long time and with such love and
such forgiveness and such mercy and such
longsuffering toward us can we continue
to live a life of sin sin broke Christ's
heart on calvary's cross and we continue
to break his heart when we sin and
that's really the motivation that draws
us away from sin to live a life of
victory in the grace of Jesus Christ
amen I find so much comfort in that
that's that's really good amen amen
Pastor densey God is not man nor does he
have human emotions like man he doesn't
feel pain fear hunger or depression how
then can he feel ours this is from Mike
out of
Michigan thank you so much uh for the
question question uh Mike uh I would
like to point to a verse to you in
Isaiah
63:9 it's very interesting to me notice
what it says in all their Affliction he
was afflicted and the angel of his
presence saved them in his love and in
his pity he redeemed them and he bore
them and carried them all the days of
old in some way that we may not be aware
of God suffers when we suffer uh he's
not like us yes you are right but in
some way that we are not able to
understand he suffers he sees the
suffering he suffers in every way
possible that we that is that is God as
only God can do but when we consider
Jesus uh he suffered all of these things
that you mentioned he he faced fear he
faced hunger he face depression attacks
of the devil unlike any person that has
ever existed or will ever EX exist
Isaiah 53 beginning in verse 3 says he
is despised and rejected by Men A Man of
Sorrows and acquainted with grief that's
right and we hid as it were our faces
from him he was despised and we did not
esteem him surely he has borne our
griefs and carried our sorrows yet we
esteemed him stricken Smitten by God and
Afflicted but he was wounded for our
transgressions he was bruised for our
iniquities that chastisement for our
peace was upon him and by his stripes we
are healed so please understand that
God's love is great greater than we can
ever measure or even imagine and he he
sympathizes with us and gives us
strength to face difficulties and so I
would encourage you to continue to
follow him with all of your heart uh get
to know him more and more and you can
see vers verses like these that help us
understand hey when I am Afflicted when
I am in sorrow God knows God sympathizes
and God somehow suffers along with me
and he wants to Deliver Us from from
depression he wants to lift us up and so
uh remember the verses that say humble
yourself in the sight of the Lord and He
will lift you up so uh please take this
into consideration as you consider this
topic about about God and emotions amen
excellent counsel excellent counsel
Pastor LOM Kang in the Book of Matthew
12: 31-32 we are told that blasphemy
against the spirit will not be forgiven
in this age and ages to come does this
mean that there is a difference between
the Holy Spirit and the son verse 32
states that speaking against the son of
man is forgivable please explain this is
from Walter out of Kenya thank you
Walter let me read the verses to you
first Matthew 12: 31 and 32 therefore I
say to you every sin and blasphemy will
be forgiven men but the blasphemy
against the holy spirit will not be
forgiven him anyone who speaks a word
against the son of man it will be
forgiven him but whoever speaks against
the Holy Spirit it will not be forgiven
him either in this age or in the age to
come now let me just bring out something
here you know Jesus was accused of
blasphemy when he was on Earth mhm and
what is blasphemy specifically they
accused him of being of being the Son of
God let me rephrase it they said that
saying that he's a Son of God is
blasphemy because they didn't accept him
as the Son of God so blasphemy has two
two actual applications one is claiming
to be the Holy Spirit or claiming that
the spirit is working and he's not
secondly is uh also offending his office
His function when Jesus forgave they
said you can't forgive sin only God can
do that once again if he was not God
that would be blasphemy doing something
that they accused him of not having the
authority to do so when you think about
the work of the Holy Spirit here two
things are pointed out one is when the
Bible talks about this in 2 Timothy
chapter 3 uh having a form of godliness
but denying the power thereof in that
context people are uh contributing the
holy spirit's work to something that the
holy spirit is not even connected to at
all that there is condemning the person
saying this is the holy spirit doing
this and the Holy Spirit I'm not doing
that denying the power thereof and so
there are many people that will do works
and I'm kind of coming at it a different
way here many people will be involved in
Works Matthew 7:
21-23 and the Lord will say I don't I
don't even know who you are I never knew
you they'll be contributing all these
works and as one very common writer said
he said 90% of What's Done in church
today will continue if the Holy Spirit
was fully withdrawn because he's not
functioning it's a form of godliness
today but the reason why this was such a
condemnation is because John 66: 7-10
the function of the Holy Spirit it says
and when he has come he will convict the
world of sin and of righteousness and of
Judgment of sin because they do not
believe in me of righteousness because I
go to my father and you see me no more
so when you deny the very existence of
the one who is to convict you of sin you
cannot be convicted of sin and like Dan
in the Old Testament you don't know you
have sinned you cannot overcome that sin
and thereby you are defaulted to
condemnation you cannot be forgiven and
that's the danger how shall we escape if
we neglect so great of Salvation they
cannot be saved if they grieve the very
one that is to convict them of sin and
then Ephesians 4:30 and do not grieve
the holy spirit of God by whom you were
sealed for the day of redemption when
you cut off the very one that says
here's your issues like go to the
dentist and get getting rid of him
you'll have cavities perpetually you
cannot cut off and deny the work of the
spirit of God and still expect to be
sealed and be saved amen amen that's
unpardonable yes yes thank you Pastor
lomma Kang Pastor rafy did Solomon write
Psalms chapter 72 and and 127 or were
they written for or to him at the end of
Psalm 72 the scripture says the prayers
of David the son of Jesse are ended this
is from Sandra out of North Carolina
thank you Sandra out of North Carolina
great question so you're correct that
both Psalm 72 and Psalm 127 begin with
the added phrase a psalm for Solomon and
this phrase is not actually in the
Hebrew text it may help to consider that
there are other Psalms like Psalm 73
that also have this added subtitle at
least in the cage J V A Psalm of with a
letter there a little footnote there of
ASF or some of the Psalms use the word
of and some use the word for ASF so a
Psalm of ASF or a psalm for ASF and this
can lead us to conclude that Solomon or
ASF were fellow authors of some of the
Psalms with David in fact many scholars
have concluded that however there's also
evidence as you pointed out that the
Psalms were authored by David for
Solomon or for ASF and in fact several
of the Psalms have this notation can be
understood as as of or for like Psalm 73
Psalm 75 Psalm 76 Psalm 77 and so on so
were the Psalms written for Solomon and
ASF or as some Scholars suggest are they
authored by Solomon and ASF like uh some
of the Psalms we've mentioned here is it
for or is it of now research shows that
there were a number of Levites that King
David assigned as worship leaders in the
Tabernacle Choir and that's according to
1 Chronicles 63 31 and 32 ASF was one of
these men 1st Chronicles 6:39 asf's
duties were described in detail in 1st
Chronicles chapter 16 and according to 2
Chronicles 29:30 both ASF and David were
skilled singers and Poets all ASF is
also mentioned as a sear or a prophet
the sons of ASF were mentioned in 1st
Chronicles 251 and 2 Chronicles 24 and
Ezra 2 verse 41 so the sons of ASF were
likely uh a a guild of skilled poets and
singers modeling themselves musically
after ASF their leader so David and ASF
were basically contemporaries both had
musical talents both were the go-to for
God's people when it came to worship now
we know today that most hymns have two
names attributed to them one for the
music and the other for the words right
sometimes one person does both and many
times but many times it's two people and
could the Bible then be noting ASF as
the musical composer to David's Psalms
when the Bible says that David delivered
first under the hand of ASF and his
Brethren one gets the this idea he
delivered his words to ASF and his
Brethren to put to music he authored it
and then it went to ASF and his Brethren
and they put it to music so the
subheading a psalm for ASF likely
suggests this Psalm was put to music by
ASF or as the text says it was given to
ASF by David what do we make of all this
well many scholars will tell us that
Solomon or ASF also authored some of the
Psalms other Scholars allow for David's
authorship for Solomon for Solomon and
also for ASF to put them to music so in
our present world we have this same
conflicting information at times there's
you know a singer who sings a song but
he didn't really author the song we
think the song is his but it's really
somebody else's and we could see the
same thing in the Psalms uh we see
though some Harmony here in Psalm 72
which clearly indicates that this
particular Psalm was was written by
David because it ends verse 20 the
prayers of David the son of Jesse are
ended and this is probably why the
Publishers of the Bible say at the
beginning a psalm for Solomon meaning
written by David for Solomon now
thankfully this auth authorship of the
Psalms is not a Salvation issue it may
be helpful for us to know that the Bible
directly connects David's name to the
Psalms and never to Solomon or ASF as in
2 Samuel 231 and Luke 20 verse 42 but we
don't need to make this a test issue
amen amen there was so much going on
there I'm gonna have to rewatch this on
3abn plus a l information a lot going
absolutely absolutely Pastor deny I
recently came across a YouTube video in
which a pastor used Hebrews chapter 7
trying to prove that the law of tithing
has changed because Hebrews 7 has
amended Malachi 3 how do you respond to
this has the law of tithing
changed thank you for for your question
and I uh I think I have to say something
about YouTube videos there are all kinds
of things in YouTube that are every wind
of Doctrine blowing there are things
there that are not biblical and uh to
listen to these things can affect what
you believe you have to be careful and
you have to compare scripture with
scripture and I would encourage you to
do this now I cannot agree with this
pastor that said that we no longer have
to tithe it is a privilege and a
blessing to tithe and God has blessings
he wants to give us when we tithe this
is saying well God has taken the
privilege of tithing away and the
blessing of tithing away if you say that
uh tithing has been removed let's go
ahead and look at Hebrews chapter 7
really quick yeah verse 11 12 and 13
therefore if Perfection were through the
levitical priesthood for under it the
people received the law what further
need was there that another priest
should arrive according to the order of
melkisedek and not be called according
to the order of Aaron for the priest
priesthood being change of necessity
there's also a change of the law for he
of whom these things are spoken belongs
to another tribe from which no man has
officiated at the altar this is talking
about the sacrificial system and notice
again Hebrews 7:18 and 19 for on the one
hand there is an annulling of the former
commandment because of its weakness and
unprofitableness for the law was made
for the law made nothing perfect on the
other hand there is the bringing in of a
better hope through which we draw near
to God this is talking about the
sacrificial system the or those
ordinances about the sacrificial system
there was a change when Christ died on
the cross those ordinances were done
away with by Christ but tithing is a
blessing that God has given to us please
understand that uh what is the tithing
used for the tithing is used for uh the
ministers and the preaching of the
Gospel do we still need ministers to
minister to people yes do we still need
to bring the gospel to people yes so
tithing is still necessary offerings are
still necessary Matthew 23:23 notice
what Jesus says wo to you scribes and
Pharisees Hypocrites for you pay tithe
of mint and anest and coming and have
neglected the weigher matters of the law
Justice and mercy and Faith these you
ought to have done tithe men ruin anest
without leaving the others undone Jesus
is saying yes you can continue to tithe
and so upon a close examination of the
Hebrews that you mentioned this is
really not referring to eliminating
tithing in Malachi notice Malachi 3 and
I hope to get through this uh will a man
beginning in verse eight will a man rob
God yet you have robbed me but you say
in what way have we robbed you in tithes
and offerings that's right you are
cursed with a curse for you have robbed
me even this whole nation bring all the
ties into the storehouse why that there
there may be food in my house it is for
support of the ministry and try me now
on this says the Lord of hosts notice
the blessing if I will not open for you
the windows of Heaven pour out for you
such a blessing that there will not be
room enough to receive it and uh you can
continue reading my time is up you can
continue reading and see there is
blessing and tithing and God will
protect you and minister to you as well
boy I almost want to read verse 11 and
12 but got read go ahead and read it
real quick and I will notice I will
rebuke the devour for your sakes so that
he will not destroy the fruit of your
ground do you want that blessing removed
I don't think so nor shall the vine fail
to bear fruit for you in the field says
the Lord of hosts you want that blessing
to be removed no and All Nations will
call you blessed for you will be
delightful land says the Lord of hosts
amen if you want to be blessed offer the
tithe to the Lord give him the tithe
that he belongs to him amen amen do not
Rob God Amen Pastor LMA Kang does the
Bible say a teenager should not have any
relationship with the opposite sex I
want to start with this a that uh one of
my favorite preachers who's now resting
in the Lord uh Elder Brooks he says
don't get behind the wheel of a car if
you don't have a driver's
license and I thought that was so
appropriate he was saying speaking to a
group of young people that are
influenced by the methods of the world
the world has given us a different
example than the Bible gives us and
there is no difference between between
youthful immorality and adult immorality
immorality is immorality there's no well
now you're 13 it's a different stage no
there's
accountability but there's no difference
in immorality and there's a scripture
after scripture talking about how
important it is for young people to
preserve themselves uh I did an example
one day and I read the scriptures here
uh I spoke to a bunch of Youth and I
gave about 60 of them I gave them a
tomato I said pass that tomato around
and when you're done bring it back to me
and some of them threw the Tomato up and
down one one threw it to the other guy
and one busted a tomato by the time it
got got back to me the Tomato was ripped
and leaking I said this is what happens
when a person doesn't understand his or
her value and they are passed around
from person to person would you bite
this apple now would you bite this
tomato no who wants it nobody wanted it
when you fail to understand your value
and what God has given to you as a young
person and you become uh familiar with
people outside of marriage then you rob
yourself even if it were not a sin you
rob yourself of the joy and the glory of
waiting until that glorious day but the
Bible does give example 1 Corinthians
6:8 flee sexual immorality every sin
that a man does is outside the body but
he who commits sexual immorality sins
against his own body that's young men
are participating in uh practices that
they should not have uh young women also
but it now narrows it down to the young
people 2 Timothy
2:22 flee also so youthful lusts but
pursue righteousness Faith love peace
with those who call on the Lord out of a
pure heart you want to have a pure heart
you know the internet nowadays has
really made it difficult Instagram Tik
Tock the list goes on and on Facebook
Twitter the list goes on and on and when
you allow this device to become the
thing by which you drink your water
every day it's polluted water MH it's
corrupting the Bible says though the
young people should stand firmly and
allow their youth to be an example to
other Youth and thank the lord we have
gyc a whole movement of young people
that want to stand firm for what's right
not all the youth are going down the
wrong road there are some young people
that want to be pure that want to know
that when that time comes hey they're
giving the greatest gift to their to
their spouse so the Bible says in 1
Timothy 4:12 let no one despise your
youth but be an example to the Believers
in word conduct and love and spirit and
faith and in purity
but if you choose to ignore all the
counsel Ecclesiastes 11: 19 or verse 9
Rejoice oh young man in your Youth and
let your heart cheer you in the days of
your youth walk in the ways of your
heart and in the sight of your eyes but
know that for all these God will bring
you into judgment not even the young
people are uh omitted from standing
before God and giving account in the
Judgment so here's my counsel
Ecclesiastes 12:1
remember now the Creator in the days of
your youth before the difficult days
come and the years draw near when you
say I have no pleasure in them when you
do it God's way time just gets better
but when you abuse yourself as you're
young you get to the point of saying
nothing really matters anymore I don't
enjoy life at all be be firm as a young
person absolutely well said yeah and
then you don't have anything to worry
about in in the judgment and not not
counting diseases now let's not even go
that far mhm yep what's What's Done in
the the dark will come out in the light
for sure and you know what if you have
God forgives God is not an arbitrary God
that he says well sorry too late he's a
forgiving God you can reaffirm your
faith with God ask for forgiveness and
move on and live a Pure Life be a new
creature in Christ a new creature in
Christ second Timothy 57 second
Corinthians 5:17 that means that there's
victory in Christ you compl in your sins
absolutely all over again absolutely
make that tomato all
good
praise God excellent illustration Wonder
excellent illustration well this program
is not over yet but we have to take a
short break we don't want you to go
anywhere we're going to kind of wrap it
up with some final thoughts when we come
back but we want you to know how you can
submit your questions we'll see you in a
moment if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God God's holy word to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
3abn.org Bible Q&A for answers from
God's word I can't believe our time is
just about up I have thoroughly enjoyed
this program but I want to open up the
floor for any final thoughts that you
guys may have just on that one question
about Hellfire you know all those who've
lived a life with uh of sin without
genuine repentance uh of sin and
surrender to Jesus Christ as their
savior are going to reap the full
consequences of their sin at the hand of
a living God who is both merciful and
just and merci ful in that Sinners will
not burn for all eternity in some fiery
pit called hell their penalty is
executed in the very presence of God
we're told in Revelation 14 8-10 and
that makes sense because God is a
consuming fire to sin yet this will be
hell it will be a fiery Lake upon which
only those can stand who have overcome
evil by the blood of the Lamb according
to Revelation 152 through five so may we
be among that number by God's grace amen
pastor densey um you know I like to read
from Hebrews uh
41314 and hopefully 15 and there's no
creature hidden from his sight but all
things are naked and open to the eyes of
him to whom we must give account Jesus
God is acquainted with your needs and
your sufferings seeing then that we have
a high great high priest who has passed
through the heavens Jesus the son of God
let us hold fast our confession for we
have a high priest who can who cannot
sympathize with our weakness but who's
in all Point temped as we are yet
without can sympathize with our he can
sympathize with us yes thank you and 1
John 2:1 my little children we could use
that for young people as well as all of
us these things are right to you so that
you may not sin but here is the part if
anyone sins we have an advocate with the
father Jesus Christ the righteous sin is
not the issue if you never repent that's
the issue amen thank you all for what
you have shared today and answering
these questions we thank you so much for
submitting your questions make sure you
continue to study God's word and apply
the principles that are found therein
until next time God bless
[Music]
you